I for one welcome our new robot
overlords meat ham a humanoid robots
that can smile Brown week or even act
drunk all but the fish of a button
wowing crowds at an electronics fair in
Hong Kong and Murray head of facial
expressions are controlled by 40 losers
these are covered with the unique
human-like skin called rubber short the
flesh rubber the ultra realistic Android
can also recognize and interprets the
expressions of real humans it comes into
contact with all right you guys know I
love these robot stories I love all the
future stories the creepy part of that I
thought the creepy part the whole thing
was pretty damn creepy but rubber rubber
flesh rubber all right you know we just
did a segment on living forever you mock
living forever Ben but robots will you
at least concede that robots are going
to replace us
yeah I mean that to some extent they're
talking about healthcare as good as more
people would lose their jobs could lose
I'm all for uh you know that piece was
like I don't how much we just show
they're a piece like a minute fifty yeah
I will link to the phone it's not that
good like because all like in that story
basically here's what we saw the robot
do like this is my camera right we saw
the robot do like nine times like that's
a separate separate eyes like it can win
to a little more than Rand Paul can do
it is very thoroughly wrecked so I don't
know man I just like and I love it one
of the settings is drunk like the debate
not a that's what you do because the
future health care that's what you want
yeah PA robot yeah yeah yeah it's great
that they made his face look like one of
the guys Robert down he fights with as
Sherlock Holmes and an alley somewhere
yeah dogs but isn't this how it starts
it starts with us looking at a robot
that's just a head on a table
blinking one way blinking the other a I
bet I know yes that that was the hand
yes fine yeah these are
around that yes well that the they keep
not getting it to go very far if he got
tangled up and confused like Siri does
and you're trying to find you know like
a place to eat and just descend into a
gas station uh that still are still
really simple we're being we're being
drawn in by fake facial features uh the
the more popular model as the Japanese
[ __ ] robot it's gonna be all hand job
robot email well that we've done stories
on cs5 at the end of that piece in fact
they're like for for health care that
that that they want to have it'll be of
the robot actually is a more
approachable woman yeah I mean I got
like I mean it's like he couldn't stand
to do the story the way like a and and
and I'm sure that yeah I mean it seems
to be where it said it anyway but I mean
why why is the if it's for health care
yeah why is the female more Pro it's a
robot right so Laurie couldn't make
difference not real
hey I'm not this isn't good for male
robot you're gonna be representing would
you be jerked off by a male robot as a
heterosexual man only on a long drive
and Oh what the hell we're not in Vegas
yet isn't all this just how we're
disconnecting ourselves
yeah humans that that's really what's
going on here that right now I just saw
another story in Japan this week they're
having a bank tellers that are robotic
that you're gonna you know it's not just
going up to an ATM machine and punching
you of course we're not getting humans
anymore but it's not just the ATM that
you're really gonna talk to one of these
things and that we're losing something
that's just very human the ability to
sit with someone and actually talk about
something and and the you know I come
from this local news background and and
I mentioned in an earlier segment but
you know we what we've lost is any sort
of authenticity
you know with we have the you know the
the reality TV worked in the beginning
with Survivor because we actually felt
like we were getting something authentic
I didn't watch it but I saw a couple
episodes and it was not so much of a
book on it um but then like local news
and the real news and everything that we
are sort of seeing now
is fake the outrage is fake were mad at
everything on the air everything is um
and so you know little things that
matter like again and an interaction
with a bank teller you know at least
it's real it's authentic and i-i-i-i
enormous liebe Mon the loss of
authenticity but what they're really is
going to be the loss of our jobs and
that's what this is mean robots it's fun
you know when you think about robots you
like doing robot storage because you
like hey it'd be great me and David will
have a robot in the house and he'll like
sweep up and division then what's David
gonna do what and do uh uh that's funny
and do and do fun stuff and we gonna buy
the robots are Kaiser and they're gonna
buy three hundred seventy-five thousand
of those robots yeah and I'll let them
fire six hundred seventy five thousand
people yeah uh and those people will
have to take you know is blue they get
the economy's better and jobs are coming
back but those are good jobs that are
coming back and those people take lousy
ER jobs and the disparity between the
rich and the poor yeah but we're mining
on Mars right so all the taxi drivers a
robot
well director but you know with robots
they'd be excellent mine Marsh miners
Total Recall one of my favorites anyway
what was boring story what's your
favorite movie no robots are they coming
to kill us let us know in the comments
right down below